democratic socialism is on the rise as
DSA membership skyrockets half of
Millennials call themselves socialists
and crazy-eyed Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
spreads the gospel of envy and the
philosophy of failure our Stalinist
comrades face just one problem there
isn't any such thing as democratic
socialism like dry water or tasty
kombucha democratic socialism is a
contradiction in terms we will analyze
why this is and will also identify the
keywords that you need to look out for
to identify brainwashed lefties we'll
talk about why ideology is terrible and
when the Left lost its sense of humor
entirely finally last but not least I'm
hoping that ambassador nikki Haley is
watching we will explain why owning the
libs is a wonderful thing I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I wish we could just jump to the end
right now and extol the virtues of
owning the libs but we'll save that for
later because it's a wonderful thing and
I could talk about it forever before
that I've got some good news folks
good news not only for you good news for
me good news for the show good news for
the cafe mic up we've got a new sponsor
purple mattress and I love this I love
any sponsor any product that can have
you thinking about me when you're in
your bedroom and purple mattress will do
just that
Birbal mattress is some pretty insane
technology also so you know obviously
these days technology is advancing
tremendously things that you know we
used to like ride the horse and buggy
just five minutes ago and now there are
all these wonderful technological
solutions to everyday problems one of
them and I face this all the time where
I did face this is that I have back pain
when I wake up so I'd always sleep kind
of wrong my neck you know wouldn't feel
great oh all messed up
purple fixes this problem purple is so
so good the founders of purple or two
brothers who've been developing
cushioning technology for 30 years for
things like medical beds wheelchairs
their comfort technology specialists and
they have created a mattress unlike
anything else this was developed by an
actual rocket scientist purple mattress
try a hundred night risk-free trial if
you're not fully satisfied you can
return it for a full refund backed by 10
year warranty free shipping and returns
no reason not to try it whatever you're
doing right now stop go to purple comm
use my promo code Kofi fait Co V Fe Fe
at check out you will get 10% off your
entire order in addition to this week's
free gift with the purchase of a
mattress this is not gonna last long go
there right right now purple comm a
promo code co f fi co v fe fe the only
way to get 10% off plus your free gift
is to use cough fa c OV e fe fe at check
out purple comm promo code cough if a
okay that now we're gonna leave the nice
things of beautiful mattresses that feel
really good and leave you without back
pain and having a good night's sleep and
we're gonna have to turn back to
socialism alright let's just dive right
in let's just dive right into the deep
end of the pool the the jackals the
hyenas at the view
or here we are debating democratic
socialism with the one same person Megan
McCain here they are
I isn't democratic socialism very close
to liberalism I mean now think about it
for a second medicare social security
guards collection the post office I
asked her this question about what do
you mean by being a Democratic Socialist
and she went over her platform
she says Medicare for all good fully
funded public schools and universities
love it paid family and sick leaves
justice system reform immigration
justice infrastructure overhaul clean
campaign finance an economy of peace
housing is a human right well I hope
Democrats do run a democratic socialism
because I think you lose spectacularly
and then I will look forward to election
night when I finally get to tell
everybody I told you so he ends up
running a radical problem with socialism
in the words of Margaret Thatcher at a
certain point you run out of spending
other people's money
Venezuela one of richest countries in
the world in the 70s now the average
Venezuelan has lost 24 pounds because
they're starving to death 90 percent I
think country - man Geneva I think she's
talking more about Scandinavia than
Venezuela oh ok ok god it's just talking
more by the way the United States has
does not have the highest economic
freedom index in the world
far from it there are countries in those
areas countries that you know the left
always likes to hold up as socialist
which have more economic freedom than
the United States does but I want to get
to the central point here as the left
embraces democratic socialism right now
the DSA membership has increased seven
and a half times in just two years
between 2016 and 2018 the membership has
increased almost seven and a half times
the dues-paying member ship which is
ironic because I didn't think socialists
paid for anything but they are paying
their membership dues now to this there
are 42 candidates across the United
States who are now endorsed officially
endorsed by the Democrat socialists of
America there is obviously Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes there's another one though
this guy as a kringles Steen up in Maine
he's
he stands with the Democratic socialists
he wasn't comfortable calling himself
one before but now he is comfortable
calling himself one this is spreading
you have the the sort of cackling lefty
hyenas on the view they're embracing
socialism they're saying isn't it just a
like liberalism isn't no it's not it's
not real socialism it's a democratic
socialism ladies repeat after me
there is no such thing as democratic
socialism repeat after me
there is no such thing as democratic
socialism miss Alexandra Ocasio cortes
is there any such thing as democratic
socialism I am NOT the expert that's a
good point far enough you're right you
know now I bet the New York Times is
gonna yell at me for spreading fake news
he didn't really interview her he didn't
Rea yeah you're right it wasn't that was
just a clip it was just a clip New York
Times there is no such thing as
democratic socialism there are
contradictions in terms you know there's
a really depressing number that's been
coming out according to two separate
studies Millennials the majority of
Millennials identify as socialists they
would they call themselves socialists
they'd rather live in a socialist
government that that number has risen
dramatically over the years even Prager
use will wit who I think was constructed
in a laboratory made by snapchat will
wit went out there and talked to these
Millennials look what they had to say
should we have more socialism in America
yeah definitely should we have socialism
in America I think we already have an
element of socialism already but I
believe in the tenets of socialism and
yes I think we should have more I mean
ideally this I mean it sounds like a
great idea
it's one of the options we haven't
really tried yet and what we have been
trying clearly isn't working what do you
think about socialism
I don't believe why do you think young
people like socialism so much
free stuff where have you seen socialism
work in the world you see even like in
Europe like France and at least they
have like socialist parties as well as
in Latin America with like Bolivia
Venezuela Venezuela Venezuela where are
you from I'm from Russia and you really
don't like socialism yeah yeah that's
right
they all say they say yeah I like
socialism look what it look it hasn't we
haven't tried it before and clearly
clearly what we're trying isn't working
I mean that's why we have the most
prosperous country in the history of the
world but we're not as like we don't
have Venezuela you know we don't have
people starving in the street or being
gunned down by their government now we
don't have that you know so clearly it
isn't working so the bad news more than
half of Millennials identify a socialist
the good news though according to other
bowls this was I think according to CBS
in New York Times is that only 16% of
Millennials can explain what socialism
is vast majority of Millennials have no
idea what it is they're frequently wrong
but never in doubt say yeah no I totally
i believe in socialism I'm a socialist
well what is socialism you know I'm not
the expert I don't what do you ask me
these questions for the socialism is is
a wicked wicked ideology and there's no
difference between democratic socialism
and socialism it's just socialism the
democratic socialists of america they I
define their agenda as saying that they
reject the economic order based on
profit what they call for is the
government control of industry
government control of the means of
production is just socialism our Veen
crystal bill Crystal's father he talked
about this in particular a number of
years ago he wrote democratic socialism
turns out to be an inherently unstable
compound a contradiction in terms
every social democratic party once in
power soon finds itself choosing at one
point after another between the
socialist society it aspires to and the
liberal society that fathered socialist
movements end up in a society where
liberty is the property of the state and
is or is not doled out to its citizens
along with other contingent benefits
there are different kinds of socialism
there's international socialism
that's communism so on the Soviet Union
there's national socialism that's
fascism or Nazism we saw it in in the
Second World War in Italy in Germany and
then there is democratic socialism but
the end of all of these socialism's is
is socialism is government control of
the means of production and as the
government grows the citizen shrinks a
government that can give you anything
you want is a government that can take
away everything that you have and you're
seeing it play out in real time it's not
just history it's not just the lessons
of history it's going on in the Latin
America right now you see in Venezuela
obviously Venezuela has the largest
proven oil reserves in the world and
they're just overflowing with energy
they could be a hugely abundant
prosperous nation and they were for a
time until they embraced socialism we're
not talking about ancient history we're
talking just a few decades ago now
because a couple decades ago they
elected socialists people are starving
in the street literally starving in the
street it's a failed state the IMF is
warning that inflation could jump to
2,300 percent it's utterly broke and
utterly failed and it's really tragic I
mean you're seeing people burying their
babies because they they starved at 16
months old 17 months old now that in
Nicaragua in Nicaragua right there
there's a crisis of socialism father
Cesare Augusto Gutierrez is warning now
but the government just do mowing people
down saying that the socialist state is
targeting its citizens the armed
socialist state is targeting its unarmed
citizens and killing them and torturing
them
there was actually a person who's an
American citizen by birth who's down
there has been tortured brutally I won't
go into the details you can read about
it in some of the accounts being
tortured brutalized names Marco Novoa by
the socialist government and right now
also the the socialist government is
defiling churches there they're going in
there they're desecrating churches and
it's because when the government has
power you have no protection for your
Liberty they use this term democratic
socialism in part because they want to
make they want to conflate socialism
with the Democratic Party that that's
actually why they're using it in America
they say oh well I'm a demo
you're a Democrat socialist kind of
close aren't they they shouldn't be I
mean perhaps now that is the case
perhaps the Democrat party's moved all
the way to the left but they really
shouldn't be the same thing you know
it's easy whenever the government wants
to take power whenever socialists want
to take power they promise the whole
world they promise you everything every
tin-pot dictator every banana republic
dictator he has a bill of rights a mile
long they say oh you'll get food and
water health care is a human right food
is a human right jobs or a human right
this and you'll get em you'll get a car
you'll get sprinkles on your ice-cream
you'll get marshmallow sandwiches you'll
get rainbows and puppies you'll get
everything but when the government has
that power when they take over all the
power you have no way of protecting your
rights you have no way of saying well
where's my ice cream they said well
we'll you'll have to wait a little bit
for that launch of yeah well listen just
wait you have no recourse you have no
defense and the government will run
roughshod over you you know if Madison
writes about this and the Federalists if
men were angels we wouldn't we wouldn't
need government at all but don't forget
those men who are taking over power in
these socialist governments they're just
like you and me they're just they're not
like some benevolent betters they're not
these angels who are going to create
wealth and prosperity and always have
the interests of everybody at heart and
be compassionate they're just people and
people are driven by the same impulses
all around there they're trying to
conflate these things democratic
socialism and the Democratic Party and
it's just part of their larger attack on
language you see they use this all the
time and before we move on just from
this question of ocasion Cortez and
Finkelstein or whatever that guy's name
is of a Ringel Steen up in Maine and the
40 other Democratic socialists endorsed
candidates I will say on the one hand
Meghan McCain is right because if they
run these lefty candidates they're gonna
not do very well in this election I
think I don't think this is a great
strategy I don't think socialism plays
in Peoria I just don't think that's
gonna work in the short run but what
they're doing is they're mainstreaming
socialism and that's a very bad thing
because socialism is tyranny socialism
is slavery that's all it is and over
time if people's defenses
immunities against this start to break
down you're gonna see more socialist
candidates come in I mean you're seeing
it over just the last two years Bernie
Sanders and the Millennial useful idiots
who supported him
are surging the membership of the
Democrat socialists of America they're
surging they're proliferating all of
these candidates and it's it's going to
get worse you know in the 2016 election
the Democrats said good nominate Trump
Oh nominate Trump he'll be the easiest
one to beat he's so crazy and out there
and unconventional right they were in
for a rude awakening and I fear that
we'll be in for that rude awakening -
it's really worrisome especially with
Millennials who don't know anything
because you know first of all
Millennials don't remember the fall of
the Berlin Wall we were born around the
time the Berlin Wall fell or shortly
thereafter
so you don't remember this the horrific
stories of communism you don't remember
seeing people being liberated from
behind the Iron Curtain you don't
remember any of those things and you
know at all times from Vladimir Lenin
and Joseph Stalin onward all the way to
okay SEO Cortez and Finkelstein or
ingolstein socialists have relied on
useful idiots you now have a whole
generation who don't remember these
things and the and they can't even
describe what it is they don't know what
socialism is they just know that they
support it I think a lot of that is
because of the ideology that they've
been educated into so I think
conservatives don't just play the short
game here don't just play yeah nominate
all those crazy socialists and then
we're gonna win in 2018 or 2020 you've
got to be careful you've got to educate
people about the the horrors of
socialism because in the long run it
could really wipe us out especially with
a generation who doesn't know anything
one way that the Democratic socialists
do this and the so-called Democratic
socialists do this is they manipulate
language this is their main technique
this is the main way that ideologies
advance themselves so you know if Ocasio
Cortez came out and she said you know
I'm a pinko communist probably she
wouldn't do that well but even if she
said I'm a socialist might not do that
well would some a democratic socialist
kind of eases it in she was in an event
with Bernie Sanders she said we're gonna
flip this Kansas House seat red in
November people thought that was a gaffe
I think that was a Freudian slip that
she was doing
you know all of this language is the
stuff of ideologies there's a great
political philosopher that conservatives
should all read and I reference him
sometimes because he doesn't get as much
play as he should as Michael Oakshott
and he defines ideology as basically
being combinations of vocabulary when
you when you want to know what if okay
what a ideology is look at the language
that people use when they're idiot logs
and there are these whole sets of
language like the left uses it today and
the left use certain language in the
1970s the left uses different language
today and non lefties never use this
language because we talk like normal
people but they talk like they're true
believers like they're in the cult an
example of this in the 60s and 70s the
left would use the word of oppression
that was the big term it was the term of
all these lefty movements but today they
don't use oppression anymore that's sort
of antiquated now they use privilege
means the same thing but that's the term
yeah well you've got to check your
privilege
how much privilege do you have these oh
he's very privileged non lefties don't
use that language but it's a it's a way
for lefties one to identify one another
and then too it shapes how they see the
world
another one is exploitation you would
always hear the exploitation of workers
or exploitation of this group of that
group in the 70s today it's classism
another one you would hear in the in the
70 should hear alliances there was talk
of that but now you're here being an
ally do you I mean have you seen this on
campus or they say you got to be an ally
what does that mean you mean be an ally
am i you've got to be an ally and for
those of us who are like normal people
we'd kind of look quizzically and then
move on but for those indoctrinated in
the ideology this oh yes I'm an ally
that's how I'm gonna view the world is a
there were the Allies and the not allies
the US and the them another one is in
the in the 70s they would use
consciousness-raising we're raising the
consciousness you know where ray is
gonna raise the consciousness now it's
calling out you've got to call out
racism you've got to call out sexism you
could call it out call it out what is
that what do you mean call it out you
start yeah yeah you know so is that your
uncle at Thanksgiving dinner says oh I
voted for Donald Trump
you yell you call it no but that's how
they view it that's what they that the
image you get in your mind because what
they really mean is disagree with
somebody or you know be mean to them or
yell at them or whatever but the image
you have is someone fam just shout it
calling them out shouting it out
stopping the conversation interjecting
yourself into it
in the in the old days it was the people
you know power to the people
now it's folks folks is one of the great
leftist demagoguery terms you whenever
it's only Democrat politicians to say
now listen folks look ah these are good
folks these people you Joe Biden would
use it Barack Obama would use it I hope
it hasn't crept too far into
conservative language they say the folks
the folks the people you know there was
another group of socialists about 70
years ago they used the Foulke a lot
they really had an ideology of the folk
and a similar background to the in the
70s you'd hear liberation they say you
got to be liberated we need to liberate
people liberate these oppressed folks
might do I do I get a prize if I use
them all in a sentence liberate you've
got to liberate and but now it's safe
space they mean the same thing they
sound like they mean the opposite thing
what liberating is being freed and safe
space is being coddled and protected but
it's being used to refer to the same
thing
they're just twisting the language and
so that you can see that twisting in the
evolution of the ideology and that this
this doesn't only apply to exclusively
activist language some of it bleeds into
mainstream but you'll notice the left
speaks in language that the right does
not speak in we are speaking different
languages and it's because the left has
a very particular ideology obviously
you've heard the phrase woke you know
woke is really good and when you're
sleeping on a purple mattress you'll
never want to woke up because if you'll
feel really comfy you know you'll be
sleeping like a baby but it what about
other language have you ever noticed
that on the left the people say that
everything is amazing this is a subtle
one because it's a normal word but it's
so overused and abused on the left say
it's amazing everything's amazing oh you
know she's amazing oh he's amazing
well usually not he because he's like a
cisgendered white male but she's amazing
this is amazing amazing amazing total
hyperbole and it
I I think the hyperbole is there to
force you to agree with them I think
it's everything it's amazing it's a miss
agree with this you're not one of us
another one is I can't even you know I
can't even usual conservatives don't use
this phrase a lot the it's usually used
by liberal white girls they were there
how much can't could a white girl even
if a white girl could not even is at an
important riddle of our a day I can't
even and and here you see the same thing
it's like the flipside of amazing it's
this dismissal it's this this these
extremes
I can't even I'm removing myself from
this if it's if it's without my
worldview that I'm not going to talk
about it the other one do you notice
lefties do this they write it on the
internet a lot that they say it to is
yes
why AAA AAAS yes and it's that same
extreme like one just to say yes yeah
yes is fine yes okay good fine very good
yeah yes they scream it at you because
you have to be as enthusiastic about all
of these ideological structures as they
are or you're not one of them you're not
an ally be an ally yes another one is
adulting no conservative would ever
earnestly use the word adulting but they
use the word adulting because they're
children so their children in like every
time they pick up a bill every once in a
while maybe they pick up the bill for
brunch and they say oh i'm adulting oh
you know i paid my rent this month i'm
adulting because you think well you're
an adult you should yes you should
exclusively be adulting it should it the
aberration should be when your child
about child adult you know but they use
it and this is an ideological word
because in their minds they are to be
coddled they are to remain in perpetual
childhood a perpetual childhood where
you don't have people say offensive
things to you where you're not expected
to work very hard where you're not
expected to fall in line and take orders
you after you you that's that's adulting
we only do that sometimes we do that as
little as we can another another lefty
millennial phrase is sorry not sorry
sorry I'm not sorry and you hear this
one a lot that's another one of like I
can't even that's another one especially
for the lefty white girls and they say
I'm so sorry I'm not sorry and it's a
sort of throwaway line but it it
actually does convey something which is
that there's no apology I don't have to
apologize for Who I am I'm great just as
I am I'm I you should love me just the
way I am I don't need to change I don't
need to try to become better I don't
need to even adult too frequently
I just I'm an ally and therefore you
know I'm sorry I'm not sorry I'm totally
I'm not considering another point of
view I'm not considering your point of
view I'm dismissing it there's a
dismissiveness to all of this language
and then my favorite one you this is the
way you know that you were talking to a
lefty and probably a millennial is when
they refer to their husband or wife or
boyfriend or girlfriend as their partner
now I'm not talking about like a gay guy
saying this is my partner that's been
around for a long time my life partner
my significant other or whatever the
euphemism is I'm talking about when a
straight guy refers to his girlfriend as
his partner or as or a straight girl
refers to her boyfriend as her partner
or her husband as her partner I've I've
noticed this with multiple acquaintances
of mine even some friends of mine so
this is my partner so and so I said oh
well you guys start a business together
did you oh really congratulations what
what business did you start oh are you
are you really are you a lesbian that
identifies as a man and therefore you're
her partner what is it because they
won't that that language is obviously
ideological the language precludes those
patriarchal structures of husbands and
wives this idea that there are social
roles that accompany biological sex that
accompany being a husband or a wife or a
boyfriend or a girlfriend it's a
rejection of that and to use that
language is to say I reject these social
roles I reject the tradition that I've
inherited I reject those things I am a
modern person who's totally free and
liberated and I reject biological
categories of sex that's what happens
when you use that and and the the same
is true of conservatives when
conservatives say this is my wife rather
than saying this is my partner you know
sweet little Elise is my partner I'm not
a man I'm not a partner I know you're my
wife I'm using it as an example when you
when you if you were to say those things
and you're saying I believe that there
is a kind of
Oracle difference between men and women
you are stating it in these days in
certain ideological quarters on the left
that is not acceptable that is not
kosher at all this this brings us back
to President Trump as as most things do
because President Trump uses language
appropriately did you read this story of
this news article about a couple with
their names are Nate and Julia sharp and
they're raising their three-year-old
twins
xyler and Caden to be gender-neutral
their their three-year-old twins islur
and Caden who definitely will not be
completely messed up and bullied because
of this terrible parenting they're
raising them to be gender-neutral
they're calling them babies you know not
him or her but they babies because I
guess they don't realize that baby is a
gender-neutral term - it's not it's like
baby is a gendered word anyway they're
raising them to be that way and it's
because they they they think very
wrongly this is a left-wing idea but
it's very stupid which is that if you
erase all the prejudices from your mind
if you erase all the preconceptions all
of the judgments from your mind then
you'll be in a tabula rasa of a
perfectly clean slate world and then you
can rebuild yourself with this new good
ideology the good left-wing ideology you
just have to get rid of all the
traditions all of the inherited
institutions all of the past and then
you'll be left to build yourself up but
that isn't true you're you it isn't like
you can have a clear mind that exists
outside of language outside of
traditions that that makes up your mind
the language that you use makes up your
mind it makes up how you see the world
you can't ever just get rid of that if
you were to get rid of all of that you'd
get rid of your mind entirely and that's
certainly what it seems like the left
has been doing you have to bring in
certain things there was that guy at the
Planet Fitness who he went into Planet
Fitness he stripped down naked they
started working out and they they called
the cops on him he said well I thought
this was a judgment-free zone I thought
this way there is that that is the
logical conclusion of the judgment free
zone there is no judgement free zone you
can't you have to make judgments you
have to discern and discriminate even
the choice by the way - Collier twins
xyler and Caden
called them babies to call them
gender-neutral and pretend the gender
doesn't exist that is a decision that is
a judgment you might pretend that that
is the absence of a judgment but any of
those things
naming anything actively participating
at all in the world is making a judgment
the question is what judgment are you
making the Trump of it all that's so
good about this is that Trump uses his
own language
you know Trump does not use these
buzzwords he doesn't use the left-wing
buzzwords he doesn't use the right-wing
buzzwords he is anti ideological he's an
anti ideological guy and that's very
good some conservatives really like
ideology I don't I I come from the
tradition of Edmund Burke and Russell
Kirk and Michael Oakshott all of these
great conservative writers who said the
before all else reject ideology because
ideology is too narrow it never takes in
the whole of human experience you're
always going to get something wrong
you're always and the further you go
down ideology the more wrong you're
going to be and that's how President
Trump is he's not a checklist kind of
guy there was a report a really good
report on the otto warmbier saga in
North Korea President Trump in the
administration getting that American
student out of North Korea even though
he'd been brutalized and and had
basically had no brain function by the
time he got back the decision to do that
if you haven't read the piece it's in GQ
it's worth checking out
the decision behind that as its reported
in that piece from Donald Trump is not
ideological he didn't run down all of
the check lists and say oh but when
we've got to do this for this North
Korean diplomat and that'll imply this
and then that this doesn't fit into this
strategy and no he didn't he saw the
situation for what it was the people in
the room said that he was behaving like
a father more than like a politician and
he said get the kid home gotta get him
home is he home is he safe is he this is
he that there's this kind of gut
instinct we in this modern world and
especially in this lefty world we like
to pretend that everything can be
rational we're if we can't rationalize
something we don't want to do it if we
can't think of the theory of something
we don't want to do it that's what the
left does that's not what the
conservatives do concert' we can rely on
other things we can rely on faith we can
rely on instinct we can rely on you know
our gut feeling and
institutions that have guided us that is
the great advantage that conservatives
have over the left the left which has to
turn everything into an ideology who
cares if it works in practice does it
work in theory
and that isn't Trump people get upset
about that they say Trump isn't
ideological enough I'll take it I am
happy to take that all the time you know
that the Trump Iran tweet the fire and
fury and it's gonna go down we're gonna
you know knock your socks off that
that's a great example of this you know
a javad zarif there which is I think
that was John Kerry's ex-boyfriend from
when he was Secretary of State
Javad Zarif the foreign minister of Iran
he responded to trumpet he said we're
not we're not impressed were not this
doesn't mean anything nonsense I think I
think you're Ron was impressed because I
think their currency which was already
at record lows plunged yesterday after
President Trump sent that tweet he's
working against the expertise of all the
technocratic sand they know so well and
they know look come on I've read all the
books and Trump hasn't read any of the
books knowledge isn't about books books
can contain technical knowledge
technical knowledge is great but there
is a practical knowledge too and that is
what this administration is exhibiting
and it and it's working and if this is
no surprise because books are just a
paltry little technical approximation of
a reality of real knowledge I have got
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
and I was just about to get to 1 to 1
the logical comedic conclusions of
leftist ideology which is the no more
comedy there's no a comedy special on
Netflix about not laughing about no
comedy it's a true story we'll play a
clip from that and and also a couple
more things to get to and I have to also
defend owning the libs before that you
gotta go to daily wire calm it is 10
bucks a month 100 dollars for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan sure you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
gets your mailbag questions in will
answer them on Thursday none of that
matters mm-hmm oh that's good
that tastes like the Iranian rial
plunging to record lows yesterday
because fire and fury are gonna rain
down from either heaven or
from whatever airplanes the United
States sends over to bomb them yeah this
is really good this is good stuff and
it's not only is it javad zarif tears
but it's also the expert tears the
expert technocratic log we know better
than trump nope no you know mmm very
good go to daily wire.com we'll be right
back a lot more to get to
[Music]
so the left has this language they have
their bundle their sack of vocabulary
that they can use that they can pick
from and it's really shrunk their world
and it's really shrunk the the
experience of the world and one aspect
of it is its deprived that world of
humor because everything now is about
being an ally and about privilege and
about intersectionality and oppression
and safe space and everything's unsafe
and you know and you've seen this over
time the lefty comedians have started
crying on air they don't tell jokes
anymore they just cry you've seen this
even college kids who are supposed to be
having fun college is a very good time I
assure you there's a time and a place
for everything in that place is college
if you spend your college experience
frowning you did it wrong you're not
supposed to do it that way but they have
to that's the conclusion of their
ideology this is now bled over into
comedy there's a comedy special app
called Nanette which is the opposite of
comedy it hears that let's just see the
trailer
[Music]
I don't feel comfortable in a small town
I get a bit tense mainly because I'm in
this situation and in a small town
that's all right from a distance people
like our good bloke
I love being mistaken for a man I
wouldn't want to be straight white man
not if you paid me
although the pay would be substantially
better I do think I have to quit comedy
though and it's probably not the forum
to make such an announcement visit i
built a career out of self-deprecating
humor and i simply will not do that
anymore not to myself or anybody who
identifies me to understand what self
deprecation means it's not humility it's
humiliation I want my story
because that's it for those of you who
aren't watching it says it's a comedy
special arguing against comedy yeah and
of course it is because in this
environment in this ideological
framework if you use the language that
the left uses if you see the world
through the lens that the left sees the
world you can't laugh what's funny
what's funny about that it's misery it's
horrible it's scary it's terrible it's
awful that is the logical conclusion of
leftism it's the preclusion of comedy
they say I think horace walpole said
this that life is a comedy to the man
who thinks and a tragedy to the man who
feels and this is like this is facts
don't care about your feelings write
this the people who elevated her any any
kind of constraint or any broader vision
than that they're miserable there
they're so sad and miserable she gets up
there I mean apparently in this special
she tells experiences of rape she's I
mean it's really brutal and they said
can't we can't do comedy no more comedy
anymore a TIG Notaro who's another
comedian she said of this special she
said quote Nanette should be required
viewing if you're a human being
it really makes takes days to take in
everything she presented to fully
comprehend it all the use of human being
by the way is another one of these lefty
words that they do where they because
they don't like gendered language they
won't even they don't realize man or
mankind is gender neutral so they'll say
human being but just be a good human
being just be a human being
and that's a more subtle example of that
too but it's a really sad thing because
her this woman's job is to tell jokes
it's comedy right but she says no no in
our work there is no such thing as
comedy not just I can't do comedy
apparently she can do comedy she is a
professional comedian she's had a career
okay she can do it what she's saying is
that the logical possibility of comedy
no longer exists and it's because of
that narrow ideology here's a clip from
the special itself we think reputation
is more
Portland anything else including
humanity and you know who takes the
mantle of this myopic adulation of
reputation celebrities and comedians are
not immune they're all cut from the same
cloth Donald Trump Pablo Picasso Harvey
Weinstein Bill Cosby Woody Allen Roman
Polanski these men are not exceptions
they're the rule and they're not
individuals there are house stories and
the moral of our story is we don't give
it we don't get up about women or
children we only care about a man's
reputation what about his humanity these
men control our stories and yet they
have a diminishing connection to their
own humanity and we don't seem to mind
so long as they get to hold on to their
precious reputation reputation hindsight
is a gift stop wasting my time
look I am angry there's a few people in
the room are going I think I think she's
lost control of attention ha any joke
coming ever or no it's just no of course
not because she's just angry
she's just genuinely very angry why is
she so angry you know comedy can come
from places of pain and that's where
comedy often does come from and what you
do is then you focus on the absurdity of
certain pain or you remove yourself from
it or the incongruity of pain and
suffering and the and the absence of
suffering you can try there are ways to
it a lot of comedy is about suffering in
pain but she says no we're not going to
do the comedy anymore no there is no
world in which we can laugh at this why
why do why are we able to laugh at pain
in the first place you know we've been
talking about comedy a lot in the in the
last couple days
can you make a joke about pedophiles can
you make a joke about murderer can you
make it yeah you can make a joke about a
lot of things you could make a joke abut
can you make a joke about the Holocaust
can you make a joke about the fall of
Rome can you make a joke about the
Vietnam War I don't know these are tough
issues can I mean could a joke be made
sure is are they all funny no it's
Carrie you've got to be careful when
you're dealing with offensive material
can you make a joke about murder yeah I
think you can can you make a joke about
all of these terrible things yeah you
can maybe you've got to be a little
careful but you can why can you well you
can make a joke about certain horrible
things because there's hope because
there's comedy right there's hope at the
end if if I think as I do think that the
that this world is in many ways terribly
fallen and sometimes absurd but that
there is redemption and hope and
hereafter into heaven and a bait if
occasion I can look forward to that will
make all of this pain and suffering in
this world look like nothing look
miniscule by comparison then I can laugh
at it I can laugh at these little things
I sometimes I joke about this because I
had G seong-ho that North Korean
defector on the show a few weeks ago and
I'll be like driving in the car and my
GPS will buzz out you know it won't tell
me to make the turn until slightly after
I was supposed to make the turn and I'll
get very angry it was awful and then
sweet little Lisa will say Mac do you
want to call G Sanko and tell him about
your terrible time how awful this
suffering is that's as true it's not the
worst thing in the world is it you know
I my GPS doesn't work it's in the grand
scheme of things doesn't really matter
but because there is a redemption
because there is there are there are
relative pieces here you can laugh at
that but if you think as a lot of the
modern left does that this world is
cruel vicious everyone's out to get you
there was no light at the end of the
tunnel there's just darkness suffering
you turn into worm food at the end if
you think that it's hard to laugh
because you despair then you have
despairing and despair means without
hope not having hope so yeah you just
bury it isn't funny that's the logical
conclusion of their worldview it's the
logical conclusion of their ideology and
their ideologies just all of this stuff
this language and
they use their every their everyday but
before we go I will point out that the
total absence of humor now it's not just
the former comedians not just Netflix
the chief Metro political correspondent
for the New York Times Shane Gould
mocker he watched this interview by
Allie Stuckey friend of the show Allie
Stuckey this mock satirical interview
where she pretends to interview Ocasio
Cortez it's kind of funny he responds in
the perfect leftist way here is that
interview Alexandria thanks for being
here thank you thank you for having me
do you have any experience that
qualifies you for this job I was growing
up during the Clinton era and then
basically when I was in middle school
9/11 happened do you have any knowledge
whatsoever about how our political
system works mmm yes it's really good it
goes on it's worth watching the whole
thing but look she's obviously on a
different set she's got a different
background she's worried different
clothing than the interviewer in the
interview without Cassio Cortez and that
interview clip between the Hoover
Institution or I'm sorry Margaret Hoover
and occasion Cortez went viral everybody
saw it right and so Allie who does
satire is doing a little satire video
and it was very funny this is how the
New York Times chief political
correspondent responded he said shame
shame gold maker gold mocker
this faked interview of Ocasio by CR TV
has nearly a million views on Facebook
in less than 24 hours interview didn't
happen it takes clips from Margaret
Hoover show and edits info questions not
labeled satire other than the winky
emoji that labels it satire get this man
up you litt sir this guy this is the
kind of breaking journalists incredible
work that we can expect from the New
York Times are you kidding me oh my gosh
first of all it's obvious satire
second of all by a well-known satirist
then it has a little winky emoji on it
alerting you that this is obviously
satire and for a clip that everybody has
seen and the left they said wait a
second this isn't real because they
don't they don't understand they don't
understand their opposition they don't
understand the world so they think that
if a confer STUV all if a conservative
does something it can never be sad tired
cuz conservatives don't do comedy they
don't know they can't be funny they
don't joke around they know they're like
mean all right racist David dukes they
can't do that right that's what they
that's what they think
and so he's alerting people he said this
is fake and then all the lefties if you
look in the little Twitter thread they
said I tried to report it yeah I tried
to report it do what doctor you say
fellas fellas there's it's something
called humor it's called comedy life
isn't so bad it's my it's okay sometimes
it's okay you can laugh a little it's
alright you're not gonna you it won't
prevent you from being an ally to laugh
a little it's okay you can no you can
that's okay you could still be a good
person and laugh every so often a really
really bizarre I mean this guy's in New
York Times writer who knows I mean who
knows where this goes for the left I
can't imagine they'll go this way
forever it's so unfunny but we'll have
to see how it goes and in the meantime
we're gonna laugh and this brings me to
my final point today in the last couple
minutes speaking of conservatives
laughing at lefties
I love nikki Haley I love ambassador
Haley I'd have to disagree with her
slightly here though she said to the T P
USA conference she said quote raise your
hand if you've ever posted anything
online to quote unquote
own the libs I know that it's fun and
that can feel good but step back and
think about what you're accomplishing
when you do this are you persuading
anyone who are you persuading we've all
been guilty of it at some point or
another but this kind of speech isn't
leadership it's the exact opposite
now this flies directly in contrast to
an important quote from Edmund Burke
that I've read for a long time
conservatism is when something triggers
the libs and the more the libs are
triggered the more country's
conservatism where it is
that's an incredible quote by the Irish
statesman Edmund Burke is that from
reflections on the revolution in France
I think it might be I
of course if if what nikki Haley is
getting at is that just poking fun at
people just to be mean or nasty or to
really make them sad or something just
doing that might be pointless that might
be stupid or ill-advised but owning the
lives is great owning the lives is one
of the most fun things in the world and
owning the libs is an important strategy
it is leadership because there are two
ways here well I suppose there are three
ways there are three ways to win back
the culture and win back the politics
the one is you can be really angry and
mean and serious and doer and debate all
the time and say no this and be really
you know straight face just like the
lefties are the humorless lefties that's
one way to do it the other way to do it
is to be funny to laugh a little to poke
fun don't constantly be earnest about
everything just poke a little fun at
these things and you'll deflate these
lefty balloons if you just make make fun
of it a little bit if you tell if you
tell the Emperor that he's not wearing
any clothes you can laugh you can have a
good time and that humor will show
people the error of their ways those are
two ways for the Conservatives to beat
the left in politics and the third way
is to outbreed them as governor mitch
Daniels told me one time he said you can
either persuade or you can outbreed and
the latter is a lot more fun so those
are the three ways that you can you can
own the culture owning the lives is a
great thing it's not necessarily
sophomoric it's not necessarily childish
it is a really fun thing to do and
excuse me one second I just have to take
a sip of my co vote mmm that's good
that's good I like that tumbler it's
it's an important thing because it's
getting to what we've been talking about
all day the moment that conservatives
stop having fun is the moment we lose
one of the great aspects of this time
that we're in this Trump era is that
conservatives are exuberant they're
having a good time they're having fun
finally and we seem like the fun team
we're the who would you want to join you
want to join the Sandra Fluke people
with their arms crossed frowning and say
that's not funny
or do you want to join the people who
are having a good time and enjoying life
it's what I noticed well I did that
blank book my magnum opus reasons to
offer Democrats a comprehensive guide I
did this
a couple months after your President
Trump won the 2016 election and it was
the perfect time because what all the
conservatives did who bought the book
and gave it to their lefty friends and
you know is they left these comments on
Amazon these reviews and they were 10
paragraphs long and they were referring
to all of these great works of
literature and philosophy and they're
just having a good time they're just
having fun
it was witty the comments I mean the
book itself is kind of an old joke
frankly but the people responding to it
the conservatives were having a really
good time and having fun and being a
little light you know the Angels can fly
because they don't take themselves so
heavily they take themselves and lightly
and we should do that too
the moment that we frown the moment that
we take everything very seriously we
become them if we learn nothing from
this this Trump era it's that it's okay
to laugh it's okay to take things
lightly
it's a freer Society when you can oh I
shouldn't have said that
oh I meant to say this yeah well you'll
get over it if when you're a little
lighter like that the the world is freer
life is a little more pleasant and the
lefties could learn a lot from it maybe
they'd have a better time if they took
our example and hopefully they will take
our example okay get your mailbag
questions in we got a lot more to talk
about I can't you know look I can't get
to everything I have to guzzle these
leftist tears before they fill back up
again go to daily wire tie calm and and
then I'll see you tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knoll Joe
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018